It's hard to believe these tiny little bubbles of life...
...could grow into 30 - foot monsters in just three years.
Already the cold was starting to get to me. We had only a few more minutes...
...and it looked like the female was all we were going to find.
But then, a trail of destruction. The smashed remains of giant octopus snacks.
Obviously, something is eating here, and eating well, apparently.
They eat crab claw.
Oh my hat!
You alright?
Hey?
Are you alright?
Scary, but he's just checking me out. I hope.
Beautiful. Absolutely beautiful.
Although giant octopi are strong, they run out of energy surprisingly fast.
They have bad circulation and need three hearts to pump their blood.
Octopus blood is weird. It's pale blue and not very good at carrying oxygen,...
...which is why they need this cold oxygen - rich water so badly.